today I'm going to show you how to move
these germinating chestnut seeds to
another location that's more conducive
to growing them out to maturity this is
optimum size for planting once they get
this big they get to be kind of unruly
but the only reason why I knew that
these were starting to germinate was
because of these little Boogie starting
to pop up out of the out of the
substrate let's go ahead and toss it in
a pot here
tap them in give me a drink of water and
repeat once you got your chestnut
seedlings potted up in their pots keep
them in a warm spot until the threat of
last frost has passed we're keeping them
on a rocket mass heater bench in our
house and then I'll give them plenty
heat and they'll grow up pretty well and
adequate sunlight comes in here to keep
them going somewhere maybe middle or
late May we'll go ahead and put them
outside in the ground and they should be
it should be good to go they should be
able to take care of themselves after
that yeah go ahead and plant the
chestnut forest and people will be
reaping the benefits for generations to
come
you